[Music]
it will probably take a few more years
until we can finally see frozen three in
theaters
nevertheless a number of theories about
the plot of the third film
are already circulating even though
there is no footage and no
official information available
regardless of whether it's about a love
story
reunions you could do without or spunky
surprises
the fan theories truly cover it all in
order to bridge the time until an
official announcement and to fuel your
anticipation a little
we have summarized the best theories for
you in this video today
before we start we'll briefly recap the
ending of the second part for you
so anyone who doesn't want to hear any
spoilers should skip ahead now
we will also quickly go into the
individual character developments
between movies 1
and 2. let's be honest there's quite a
bit that should be briefly reviewed here
we go
ana realizes that the only way to free
the enchanted forest from the magical
mist
is to destroy the dam this was the one
her grandfather had built for the
norfolk drought on the basis of false
promises
although she knew that the water masses
would destroy arendelle
she'd get the earth giants to tear down
the dam this releases elsa from her
curse
allowing her to escape from athalan she
also finds out that she is the fifth
elemental spirit which must restore the
balance between the spirits
she rides towards arendelle as fast as
she can on the enchanted horse knock to
save the city from destruction
she is even able to bring olaf back to
life who fortunately still retains
all of his memories after all as we have
learned water does have a memory
kristoff also finally manages to propose
to anna after two long hours and elsa
realizes that her future lies not in
arendelle but in the enchanted forest
within northuldra and his spirits
so in the end ana has become queen after
all
so it can be said frozen 2 was more than
just a feast of emotions
suspense feelings jokes everything was
provided
especially the character developments in
contrast to the first film were clearly
visible
fan favorite snowman olaf who was mostly
known for his childish emotions in the
beginning
suddenly starts asking profound
questions about life and frozen too
so one could suggest he's growing up
kristoff is no longer just the unknown
iceman
instead he grows into his role as a
slightly different disney prince
he also works hard on his boyfriend
traits and spend 75 percent of the film
figuring out how to propose to anna she
on the other hand
is hardly recognizable there's not much
left of the naive princes from the first
part
rather she is struggling more than ever
to keep her family together and to make
sure that
everyone protects each other in the end
it is her who is willing to make great
sacrifices to restore peace between the
spirits
now elsa has finally overcome her fear
and acknowledges what she is
although she doesn't even really know
that at the beginning of the film
obviously in search of the truth she
comes increasingly closer to her true
destiny until she finally realizes what
she is at the end
thus she can finally leave the chapter
of being a queen behind her and follow
her destiny
last but not least we still have sven of
course though what can we say
sven is perfect as he is because let's
face it reindeer are better than humans
anyway
after it took almost two whole movies
for princesses
we mean queen anna to finally get
married fans all across the internet
agree that it's slowly but surely time
for elsa to find her great love as well
the question that arises now is of
course who do we already know her future
husband and
this is exactly the point where we
intervene and say who's even talking
about a future husband
anyone who watched the second part
attentively must have noticed that there
was
always a bit of chemistry between elsa
and the nuffield rouhani marin
we would be very happy for the two of
them elsa actress idina mensla also said
in the run-up to the second film that
the relationship between the two reads
as if many things
point to a love story in the third part
and we all know that
love is an open door still even if elsa
fails to find the great romance she will
certainly be
busy with all sorts of things in the
third installment of the series
after the mist is lifted and the
enchanted forest is now free
this naturally harvests all sorts of
dangers
as seen in part 1 arendelle not only has
allies as there are also countries that
look upon the kingdom with envy
so it's quite possible that the one or
other villain wants to use the power of
the spirits in order to plunge
arendelle into chaos again although
needless to say they would have to get
past elsa first
but not only are there dangers lurking
from the outside in the past
many people from arendelle itself were
reluctant if not distrustful of magic
above all anna and elsa's grandfather
king rooneyrt
therefore it would be reasonable to
think that there could be another plot
against the norfold and the spirits of
the forest which must be thwarted by
elsa a rumor that is spreading through
the internet but that everyone hopes is
not true
is the return of huns you guys don't
remember exactly who hans is
well it's understandable that you forget
about that little creature
so we're going to jog your memory one
more time he is the youngest of 12
brothers from the royal family of the
southern islands
recognizing that he will never amount to
anything in life he tries to overthrow
elsa
in fact he almost succeeds in doing so
by pretending to love anna who was still
very naive at the time
he will surely not be able to enter
arendelle simply like that again but
with the enchanted forest
a whole new world has opened up for him
it would be conceivable that he would
like to get hold of the forest similar
to the kingdom
besides it would not be totally out of
the question that he might try his luck
with aranel once again now that the
mighty elsa is no longer queen
perhaps with the help of his brothers or
possibly with an
army at the end of frozen two there is
much talk about
anna's big day but it quickly becomes
clear that this is not about her
marriage to christoph
rather it's about her coronation so it
remains to be seen whether the two
haven't gotten married yet
if they haven't we really hope to see
their wedding in the third part
not only since they aren't the typical
disney couple but also because the
wedding could be the focus of a larger
story what if hans came and kidnapped
anna
all of sven christoph and elsa would
then have to go looking for her in order
to rescue her
possibly sven and kristof would crash on
one of the tours
although that would be a little too
lackadaisical for a frozen part for sure
no matter how this story surrounding the
royal wedding might turn out
it is clear that we absolutely want to
see it
the only royal wedding that we would
actually watch in theaters
elsa now known as the snow queen after
part 1 is renowned as being capable of
turning anything into ice
but what about anna does she really have
no more powers beyond her courage and
willingness to give her all for the ones
she loves
fans on the internet aren't sure and an
increasing number of rumors suggest that
anna learns she can control fire hints
about this can be found in the film if
you search for it the most
obvious one is of course that her sister
possesses powers
moreover ana herself has red hair the
color of fire for example whereas elsa
has whiter
matching her eyes powers yet the
character traits of each
also match their abilities while elsa
seems rather calm
reserved and a tad cold anna is
consistently hyperactive
wild and unstoppable a conceivable
scenario would be that
anna acquires her abilities and is
unable to cope with the destructive
nature of fire
much like her sister in part one elsa
must then rush to the rescue and help
her deal with the power and her newly
acquired talent
absolutely a scenario that we would find
more than just exciting
though not only anna and elsa could be
made the focus of the events
many fans would certainly also be happy
about a prequel to the snow queen series
in which the adventures of their parents
are illuminated in more detail
the story around king angar and queen
eduna is capable of filling more than
just
one movie now that we know how the two
met many questions remain unanswered
what happened to eduna after the
catastrophe in the enchanted forest
she surely did not stay at the royal
court so how did she grow up
after what happened her life as nothing
must not have been easy in arendelle
on the other hand it would also continue
to be exciting around anger after all he
became king overnight and yet he was
still a young boy without a father
the first years of his regency would
provide suspense on the screen for sure
finally their love story could be told
which would surely be almost as
thrilling as that of their daughter
though there are plenty of other
characters from frozen that have
exciting stories as well
lieutenant destin matthias for instance
many people would surely be interested
in what became of the soldiers from
aaron hill
after they were trapped in the mist or
what the life of loyal matthias was like
before the disaster
not only him but also olaf yelena the
trolls oaken and sven
all of these characters have the
potential to fill a film in which the
two sisters would at best play a
supporting role
so that was it our theories around a
sequel to frozen
which ideas appeal to you the most or do
you even have one that we didn't take up
at all
let us know in the comments if you liked
the video then be sure to give it a
thumbs up
apart from that it's just a matter of
time until we finally get our hands on
some official information
you can always stay up to date on our
youtube channel or on our homepage
www.kinocheck.com
see you next time
you